blender on linux is it capable of doing
video editing now i've done video
editing with blender in the past but of
course i was using windows
but now i'm on a linux machine here and
specifically i'm using
mx linux which you can find online
it's a another it's one of the popular
os's right now it runs on debian
and of course you can get blender
through their package manager so you can
just go to their package manager
type in your password and go get it
it's in here somewhere you just have to
search or you can just launch your
terminal
and through your terminal you can
install it that way
all you got to do is sudo apt
install blender
ask for your password
and uh it's locked because i have this
package
thing open okay but there it is right
there as well
so you can click it and then go install
well it has a reinstall button for me
right now because i've already installed
it
but okay so if i close that let me just
close blender for a second
and now we try to install it's not
locked anymore and it says blender is
already installed but if you don't have
it
you'll install it and this will stay up
to date
as this most stable one that uh your
linux distro provides so blender has
updated a little bit since then
but this is still the one they recommend
the one that comes with their packages
and it will auto update
when it needs to so that just makes it
awesome for maintaining so let's go
ahead
and cover up our moss goriac i think
that's what that is with blender
so launching blender here and let's just
go ahead and go up to file at the top
left and then click new and we're going
to click video editing
and this brings us to a special video
editing setup
for blender you'll see video editing and
rendering up here
now for example though if you're just in
the general one
you can still go to video editing from
this plus way up here
and just go to it from here
and then you're in the general view with
the video editing tab added so however
you want to do it is fine as long as you
get to this video editing
set up with the sequencer the preview
previewer your
scene settings and your files over here
of course you can morph around blender's
interface a little bit if you want
that's kind of out of the scope of this
video so i'm just sticking with
all the defaults
all right so the first thing you want to
do is you want to set up your project
and you also want to of course have a
video ready so it's kind of both of
those things
but i always like to do this first here
go over
to the settings and then go to the
output and find the render
place so i have a folder just in my home
folder called renders and i'm going to
put it right in there
if you don't choose it'll just go to a
temp directory
and also you want to go down to file
format
and change this from png to ffmpeg video
that sets it up to render as one of the
most common
formats that everything can read also
you want to expand out in coding
like i just did there and you want to go
ahead and get some messages
and interrupt your video right in the
middle of your recording that would be
great too
okay muted and
then you want to also go down to audio
here
and change this to aac
and that's good enough to get a half
decent render
i wouldn't recommend changing any other
things unless you're willing to get some
varying results
so those are the basics right there so
i'm just going to collapse those you
don't need to do whatever now at this
point
you generally want to save i'm going to
drop a video in here first before saving
it
so you can do this however you want you
can grab a video from your phone
you can record something with a screen
capture like obs
or maybe your webcam but basically any
video that you have as a file on your
computer
you can navigate to it and bring it in
you can also drag it in
from your file explorer if you've got a
video somewhere in
here so let me just see here videos
so i could drag it in this way and it'd
be happy or i can navigate to it
from my file explorer here and you see a
bunch of little commands
you can hover over these to get a pop-up
of what they are
one of them's like create a new folder
go back a directory refresh
some basic folder operations so i'm
going to grab just a random video
usually you want to start with a
small one so go ahead and take the time
to get a small video of your own if
you'd like to follow along
but if you're just watching and learning
that's fine too
all right so i'm going to grab let's say
this video i don't really know what this
is i think this is some coding video
i'm just going to drop it in here so it
adds it as a new strip
and you can see two different colors uh
this bluish one
is the video i guess they're both bluish
and this teal-ish one
at the at the bottom is your audio
the first thing i like to do well let's
go ahead and save
first of all this way we don't have to
redo those properties
and uh saves that has a something.blend
it's a blender file
i'm just gonna call it asdf for now
that's fine with me
click save blender file over here
and there we go now if something happens
to crash or we have to
leave or quit the program for whatever
reason we can come right back to this
and we have all these settings because
it's always a pain to have to redo these
settings
you might be able to default them
somewhere but i'm not going to look at
that right now
all right so you can scroll out with
your mouse wheel or if you don't have a
mouse wheel you can grab the ends of
these little
um bars they've got a little tiny dot
and if you click the dot you can just do
it that way and you can do it
for the vertical as well over here
so mouse wheel is your friend for
getting around your
your video and you can hold control
while you're scrolling to move about as
you can see i'm going left and right
i'm still using the mouse wheel and if
you can hear it but i'm just holding
ctrl
so those are some basic controls to get
you to to move around and you move your
play head up here
now you can see this little area that's
kind of highlighted that's the current
render area so if i hit like play right
now
it'll just cycle that over and over
playing
so there we go it just starts it over
and to change that
you got to do that down here at the
bottom right it has a start and an end
frame
also i forgot to mention when you drop a
video in it automatically adjusts your
frame rate to that video
so if you're doing multiple videos you
need to have them all the same frame
rate or from the same device
or you can use some other program to get
them all to this exact same frame rate
before bringing them into blender if you
need to
that's pretty standard for video editing
just thought i'd mention it though
because it can be
a source of annoyance blender doesn't
handle multiple
frames very well so if you have a 60fps
video and a 30fps video
and then like a 29.00 and you try to put
them all together in blender it's
it's not going to do well so you just
need to use something to get them all
the same
first all right but
okay so let's change this to to be the
length of our video
so that's kind of the first thing you
need to do is just adjust those
so let's go to the end and you can do
this by hovering your mouse in this
sequencer area and holding
or just pressing page up and page down
goes the other way
all right so now that we're at the end
we see that we're at frame
10 38 so we're going to copy that and
just put it as the end
hit enter all right so that will change
the render time in the view time so now
we got the whole thing
alright so we could render it like this
but what's the point it's just the exact
same video basically just
re-rendered uh nothing really different
other than it's going to lose a tiny bit
of its original quality
so maybe you want to do some cuts uh
cuts are the big thing
to cut any of these you've got to click
on it and highlight it and then press k
i'm going to undo that with ctrl z
because generally you want to
keep these together you see we've got a
video in an audio and you can multi
select with shift
or by clicking outside them and making a
box
so that's the way you want to get them
both and then press k
now k is a soft cut which means you can
you can basically repair it so i'm going
to highlight these ones over here and
i'm going to press the g
key for grab and grab allows you to
start moving around
and you can lock this move around by
pressing x to lock it to the x-axis
or y to exit lock it to the y-axis
or if you want to not have it locked at
all you can just hit escape
and start over by pressing g again all
right
so k being a soft cut
lets you basically click on the end of
these
where there's a little arrow and you can
multi-click by holding control
to select ones of the same starting
point and press g
and expand it out so i'm not actually
moving the file there let me zoom out a
little bit
not actually moving the file i'm
expanding it back so the soft cut
allows you to repair now i'm going to
hit escape here to cancel that
and i'm going to grab these and put them
back down here
when there's an empty space like this
and you want to just pull this
back and line it up you can uh while you
have your mouse hovering in the
sequencer area press the
backspace key and it'll pull it back
all right so that's that uh let me just
show you a few other things
so on this audio i'm going to hit
actually ctrl z a bunch of times and get
this back to its original state
there we go so i'm going to click on the
audio here and i'm going to do a display
waveform it's very handy to know
where your waveform is changing and
where the sounds are
so i generally turn that on and as you
can see here you can adjust the volume
and the pitch so
once you do some cuts say you want to
cut this part out you go here
and maybe you want to cut to right here
where the audio starts again
you can grab the ends
press g and just pull it in and to be
precise you can hold
shift and it moves slower
and more precise there you go and then
maybe you want to back it up with the
backspace
and now you can see the endpoint has
changed so you so when you're ready to
render
you would go over here and change this
to the new endpoint
there you go so you cut out a little
portion of your video
now there is so much blender can do the
sky
is sort of the limit i'm just going to
show you a few more basic things
a few more cool effects you can bring in
photos and videos
so up here so you can drag them in from
your file explorer or you can use this
file
explorer area i'm just going to go up a
directory up another directory and
into pictures and i'm just going to grab
this random wallpaper here
actually i'll grab this blender logo and
i'm just going to drag it in here
and it kind of looks like a video except
it's stretched by default it stretches
it out over your whole screen which
isn't always what you want maybe it's
fine
but as you can see you can zoom in a
little bit here
so zoom in a little bit here use control
scroll
to move over you can grab the ends and
press g
and move it and
if it's above the video it'll always
show if it's below it won't show
as long as something's above it all
right so
with this you can do things to it over
here
and its properties like change the
opacity of it
and if you don't want it to stretch over
the whole screen you go down to this
transform and you click offset
and that way it gets it back to its
normal form and it's just at zero zero
here
so you can expand out this offset and
change its position
maybe you want it somewhere else
and you can go through the rest of these
settings and mess with them if you want
to see what they do
but that's generally the main thing you
want to do is change the offset and
change the position if you don't want it
stretched over the entire screen
all right well what else to cover here i
guess i could cover a little transitions
so if you want to transition um
two video files to make a little fade
what you do is you go
and you grab one set of them and move it
to a different area i guess the audio
could
well i'll do something with the audio so
you bring it up above it or something
like
like so and then i'm gonna
grab these and move them and overlap
them just slightly i'm holding shift so
i can kind of control it usually you
want like a specific
two second overlap or so
and i'm sure like advanced video editors
but no more tricks like the j cut
and stuff like that i'm not really going
to get into that so basically what you
do here to crossfade them is you grab
this one and hold shift and you click
the other ones so you just
click them both and now you can go
add and in here there's transitions
and you see cross gamma cross or white
so cross and gamma cross kind of do a
fade like effect
wipe does the uh like a wiper type
effect
when you click it add one you get this
brown area of where it happens and you
can kind of scroll over it and see it
happen
see what you're working with now it's
not going to be too obvious here because
it's see
it's wiping to the exact same screen
basically
you know it's just a code editor but if
it's a it's a
pretty if it's a pretty drastic thing
like a completely different clip
the uh transitions more obvious this is
just a bad example but that's how you do
it you just select them both
and go to add transition audio you can
do a similar thing
people always say what do they always
say you add the new audio in or
something first is like the j cut i
don't remember
exactly but also you can just cross fade
audio
so you can change the length so you can
crossfade it by just highlighting them
both
and going to add i think it's transition
and then sound crossfade
and there this sound will crossfade not
going to do a whole lot here once again
because it's such a basic
example all right so there's a little
bit of crossfading there's a little bit
of adding images let's say you want to
do fade in fade out there's multiple
ways to do this
my favorite way to do this is go to
where you want the fade to
start and then go up to add and then
color
and it defaults to a black color so
this color what you can do with it is
you can
timeline it in uh so this will introduce
timelines as well which is another
important little thing let's say i
wanted to be a little bit longer
looks like this is one second two
seconds so about two seconds of fade in
here
so at the beginning it's going to be
fully dark the alpha's going to be
one so i've got this
at the beginning already i've got my uh
little cursor thing or whatever this is
at the beginning so i'm going to go over
here to the opacity and hover over it
with my mouse
and then what you do after hovering over
it you press i
and that inserts a keyframe so basically
it's going to remember
that the opacity is one right there and
be ready to change
slowly to where you adapted next so
let's go to the end actually let's use
page up to snap to the end there
and at the end we want this opacity to
be zero so change it to zero
hover over it as you can see it's this
color indicating that there are other
timeline events on this uh or other
frame events on this
property so we're going to press i
to add another keyframe so now we've got
a keyframe at the beginning and the end
at the beginning it's one and at the end
it's zero and as you can see as you
scroll
you can see the effect happening so
that's one way to do fades
and you can just do a reverse of that to
fade out
so that would be a fade in say if at the
end you want to fade out
you do a very similar thing let's go
over here click add
color let's go over to it
and we'll just snap this to the end so
i'm going to click this
press g and then if you hold ctrl while
you got something you're moving around
if you hold ctrl it'll snap so sometimes
that can be handy for getting things to
the end
uh there we go we'll get it right there
uh it's not quite perfect it doesn't
there goes snapped
so that's approximately a two second
fade out there
30 seconds to 31 and a half maybe a
little bit longer
trying to get to two seconds so what we
would do is the same thing here i'm
going to hit page up to snap to the
what would be the beginning there change
this alpha to 0
and press i and go to the end i'm going
to do
page up make sure you click on it to
have it
selected change this to one and press i
so now we got it fading
the the darkness is fading in which has
the opposite
effect to the video of course so that's
my favorite way to do fades
uh you can do it by alphaing out your
video too because your video has an
alpha i just like these because you can
move them around and like
adjust them properly because if you end
up changing your video
you can take this fade and take it
somewhere else and you can also
copy it so say you want to fade another
part of your
your video somewhere you can just grab
this hit ctrl c
and paste it that way you don't have to
alpha a bunch of clips you just have one
little thing that's a
fade out and one little thing that's a
fade in you can reuse them if necessary
so i'm going to erase that one all right
so we've covered a
lot you can also bring in audio clips if
you want to put music
over your your stuff let me see if i've
got any here
i'm gonna go to uh
music here we've got some kind of coding
music oh this is really long
so it'll just play over the time and
it'll be super loud usually
so you typically want to take this and
you can adjust its volume and you can
keyframe its volume
to adjust it at different times in the
video typically if you want it as
background you want to lower it a ton
like maybe even a 0.1 or something
but obviously don't use copyrighted
video and upload it to youtube
you can go find their audio library and
download them and bring those in if you
want to use
youtube's free audio so
just so you know how to do that that's
how you bring in audio and just
make it has a little backdrop all right
well i'm going to go ahead and delete
that audio because
i'm sure it's copyrighted and i don't
want to
give you guys the wrong idea all right
so i think that's enough for this video
let me know if you'd like to see more or
if i'm missing anything else that you
know you can do but
aren't sure how to do i could probably
tell you just let me know
um let's see here when you're ready to
render all you do is you just go to the
very end here
and make sure your keyframe at the end
is correct looks like it's 9 41.
and the starting one is one so that's
your whole render area
and double check that your properties
are as you want them before you render
probably want this to be 100 1920 by
1080 is usually good
and uh yeah just make sure you got that
encoding correct
make sure the video is going where you
want it you got it set to ffmpeg video
and that you set the audio to aac those
are the big things
just to make sure that you actually get
audio you actually get video and you
know where to find
your file so then you go up to render up
here
and go to render animation which is
control
f12 as a hotkey and once you do that
it'll pop up this window and basically
start
showing you what it's doing you leave
that up if you want or you can just
close it
and it'll stop the render
but there you go once you have it
rendered you'll know where to find it
it'll just be in this folder
on your computer and you can do whatever
you want to do with it next
good luck happy video producing
blender is great it can do pretty much
everything all the big editors can do
including adding in 3d objects because
of course
and lighting and stuff like that because
blender is just a
3d modeling application and it just
happens to have all this video
editing support within it as well which
i think is great
and i use it all the time all right
we'll see you in the next video don't
forget to
like this video if you enjoyed it or if
it helped you and also subscribe to the
channel
for more tutorials and if you want to go
the extra measure
you can check out my patreon link below
and i'll be sure to do something cool
for all the people who
do support me thanks and have a good one